hey you guys we're doing another
flickers of fear show today this is my
movie review show
now interestingly the movie that i'm
going to be talking about today was not
the movie that i was originally going to
be talking about today
but this is how it happened so this
movie which is called
x the man with the x-ray eyes and it
came out in 1963.
i had actually been meaning to watch
this movie
since way back in the 1980s when stephen
king
talked about it in his book dance
macabre which if you haven't read it's
non-fiction
and it came out in the early 1980s and
he talks all about
horror in literature movies tv pretty
much every format you want to imagine
between 1950 and 1980 and he
talked quite a bit about the man with
the x-ray eyes and i had actually never
seen it
so i was scrolling through tubey a few
days ago and i saw that they had just
added it and that you could watch it for
free i believe you can also watch it for
free on youtube although i'm not
entirely sure about that but as of this
recording you can watch it for free on
tubey so i decided i was going to go
ahead and pull the trigger on it
instead of doing the movie that i was
originally gonna do because i've always
been
i've just always wanted to see it
because like the way he talked about it
like sounded really cool
and i will say that i'm really really
glad i watched this now
don't go into this expecting like some
big lost masterpiece or anything like
that but
that said this was actually a really
good
and surprisingly effective little sci-fi
horror thriller and it was written and
directed by roger corman of all people
who like i said i
i feel like people when you'd say oh
it's a roger corman movie
yes he did make a lot of bad movies but
he was
a businessman he was very successful he
actually did care about his movies and
you know he not only made some decent
movies in there uh
you know like all his poe adaptations
which i think are fantastic
but he also gave a lot of uh
very famous filmmakers francis ford
coppola for example
uh their start in film he also gave jack
nicholson i believe his first acting
role
so he's kind of like a little bit of a
star maker kind of
even though his movies are kind of seen
as maybe schlocky
and some of them are but this one not so
much i think this one had some kind of
schlocky aspects to it
but the thing that i liked about this
one is that the implications of it
if you think about it are really really
horrifying
right so like i said this movie which is
just sometimes just called x sometimes
it's called x the man with the x-ray
eyes
it stars ray milan and as i mentioned it
came out in 1963. now when it was
originally
uh released i think it was released as
like the second part of a double bill
with francis ford coppola's first film
which was dementia 13
which i'll do a review of that one day
too because i really really dig that
movie this one for some reason i always
perceived that this one was black and
white maybe because dementia 13
is but this is not black and white it's
it's technicolor
so i don't know where i got that idea
maybe it's just because in the stephen
king book that you know i had the
paperback and it was all black and white
pictures and i think he had a picture
from this movie and it was black and
white so maybe that's i don't know why i
perceived that but it's in color so
raymond
plays a character named dr xavier no
they did not get it from the x-men
because i think the x-men comic didn't
come back
didn't come out until later the same
year that this movie came out so i don't
so they weren't like copying or anything
like that
now i'm not entirely sure like what kind
of doctor he is but he's just like a
general practitioner i suppose
but he's also doing like some research
on the side and he has become
um really obsessed with
human vision and how it's really not all
that good actually like we can only say
say this in the movie i don't know this
is not entirely accurate but he says in
the movie it's no
humans can only see like 10 percent of
the visible spectrum
at the beginning of the movie he has
been getting some funding from this
foundation
and he's developed this serum which he
very creatively calls x
which they're essentially eye drops and
when you put the drops in your eyes
it kind of gives you the ability to see
through [ __ ]
what good would this be you might be
asking but his kind of thing because
he's a doctor
he thinks it would be good if doctors
could see through
their patients so you could see what was
the matter with them like inside
and he does actually use that ability
like later on in the movie so he's
working on it
and he's sort of frustrated a little bit
because he's getting like some blowback
from the foundation that's
uh you know giving him the money to fund
the research in particular this one
doctor dr fairfax and she uh
is kind of like the overseer of his
project so she's kind of always
i mean she really actually likes him and
thinks his work is interesting and they
kind of have a little
bit of a romantic thing going on too
like not
overtly but it's kind of like a little
flirtation or whatever but she's sort of
you know she's the person at the
foundation that has to come and make
sure that you know he's doing the
research and
are they still gonna fund it and blah
blah so
he's been working on this [ __ ] and he's
like the stuff works but
so far he's only been able to experiment
on animals
and there is one scene in there where
they take like a monkey which is a real
monkey
and uh drop some stuff in its eyes or at
least attempt to because the monkey's
just like dude what are you doing not
gonna
so the experiment he's done this on the
experiment the experiment on the monkey
and apparently the monkey is developing
the ability to see through he has like
these three different colored like
sheets of paper or cardboard or
something
and uh he's like here's i'm gonna put
the white one in the front you can't see
the other ones
and the monkey knows to turn on the
colored light that corresponds to
the sheet that the colored sheet that he
sees in front of him
so he turns on the white one which is
the one in the foreground
but then he turns on the other two like
the red one and the blue one he's like
oh and that means that he can see
through the white one and he sees the
other two colors as well
so he's really into this and you know he
kind of explains to
uh dr fairfax like what the applications
of it would be like i said particularly
he wants it for medical
research so he can see into patients
bodies so he can help people
and she's kind of jazzed about it too
but
the foundation not so much they don't
really see any value in it and basically
they're going to tell well they're going
to cut off his funding and there's all
this other kind of like [ __ ] [ __ ]
about it
so he decides that experimenting on
animals isn't going to cut it so he's
going to experiment on himself
in the tradition of mad scientists uh
throughout history so he started
stripping stuff into his own eyes
now at first it seems kind of awesome
like he can sort of he can see through
pieces of paper and a piece of paper
underneath
uh you know so he's like hey i can read
that underneath and they're like wow
that's pretty neat uh and then there's a
thing where
one of his uh fellow doctors has
diagnosed this one little girl
with i can't remember what it was but it
was like something to do with her heart
or lungs or something
and he was gonna do surgery on her the
next morning but then dr xavier goes in
there and he's just like oh [ __ ] like he
that he misdiagnosed her and if he does
what he's
gonna do with the surgery tomorrow she's
gonna die because he's gonna be cutting
in the wrong place
you know there's a whole thing like that
so he kind of gets into
trouble with the medical establishment
even though he turns out uh it turns out
he's right
um that he's kind of like usurping other
doctors uh you know diagnosis like
stepping on their dicks essentially
uh so there's that and there's also kind
of an amusing scene sort of early on
where he goes to a party with dr fairfax
because like i said they have a little
flirty thing going on
and uh he sees everybody at the party
naked so that's like
it's kind of like played goofy but it's
like it's so funny because
raymond is like the whitest [ __ ]
in the world and it's like he goes out
to dance like at this party and it's
just like i don't even know
i don't even know if there's a name for
the dance that he does and it's just
like it's funny because all the people
at the dance
i guess they were trying to do like a
modified twist sort of dance which i
guess was like kind of popular at the
time
but these people are all kind of like
older because they're all like doctors
and academics and stuff so they're not
like teenagers
so i think it would look less ridiculous
if it was like a party full of teenagers
doing that stupid dance
but the fact that it's kind of all these
middle-aged funny duddies just makes it
like
way funnier and it's like it is and as
uh awkward as everyone's dancing is at
this party
ray milan's dancing is like a thousand
times more awkward and it's just a joy
to watch
so i just thought i would put that in
there this isn't like a funny funny
movie
but that scene is like totally funny
where he starts seeing through
everybody's clothes obviously they don't
show anybody naked
but they do kind of like show oh bare
legs and uh
you know people's from their shoulders
and it looks like they're naked and
everybody's just kind of twisting around
the funny thing to me too is that dr
fairfax who knows what he's been up to
and knows that he's taken the eye drops
right
and she like twigs on to the fact that
he's like oh you're looking at me naked
right now and she doesn't seem like
offended she's just kind of like oh you
you know what i mean it's like it's like
really really funny the whole scene is
like really funny like i said it's not a
comedy but there is like some funny [ __ ]
in it
so as i said he gets uh in trouble with
the medical establishment for
he what he does is like during the
surgery on the little girl where like i
said the
initial surgeon like misdiagnosed and
he's like you know you're gonna cut in
the wrong
place so basically what he does is he
snatches the scalpel away from the other
surgeon and like cuts his hand and he's
like there [ __ ] you you can't do it now
and i'm gonna do it
and like i said even though he turns out
to be right like the other doctor is
like super pissed off
and so uh you know he's like oh you're
going to get sued for malpractice and
blah blah blah
so at this point he's he's kind of on
the outs a little bit he's lost his
funding for his research
um and he only has so much of the serum
left
and it seems that he's sort of become
obsessed too with taking more of it
i think there's an implication i was
watching another review of it and they
said they didn't really
understand why he would keep taking it
because as the movie goes on
it's almost kind of like it's like a
jekyll and hyde situation where it's
kind of like
he puts it in his eyes and he can see
through stuff it's not i don't think
it's constant
but it kind of comes and goes um and
then like the more that he takes and the
longer the movie goes on like the more
[ __ ] he can see through like he can
start seeing into people's bodies like i
said and then
then he starts seeing kind of you're led
to believe like sort of
through like he sees all the invisible
light spectrums and you start seeing
maybe
toward like beyond the bounds of the
universe type stuff you know which they
get into a little bit later
so it does kind of go in a little bit of
a cosmic horror direction surprisingly
uh but so there's that but he still
keeps taking the drops anyway and i th
but i think the implication is that you
know because your eyeballs are
you know attached to your brain
obviously so i think maybe
that the uh the drops are maybe
affecting his
brain or you know his thinking pattern
as well and almost
and it's almost kind of like an
addictive uh thing too because he's
almost kind of like
it gets to a point where he can't really
sleep anymore because even when he
closes his eyes
obviously he can see through his eyelids
which is like horrible
so he just sees light all the time he
can't have dark
so as the movie goes on like after he
gets sort of
in trouble and um you know has to sort
of
there's a point too where he gets into a
fight with the surgeon uh you know and
he
accidentally sort of like pushes him out
of window he doesn't push him out of
whatever kind of knocks him out a window
and because he'd been acting sort of
crazy
um you know dr fairfax is like no one's
gonna believe that was an accident
you know even though it was an accident
so you need to get the [ __ ] out of dodge
so he has to pretty much like take off
and from that point
he has to start wearing these like super
super dark glasses
now it's really weird because like the
first half of the movie
is him just getting more and more like
taking more of the drops and being able
to see more and more he's essentially
like
you know he could see into people's
bodies and see through things
and all this other stuff but not all the
time it's like really uh you know
intermittent i guess
so after the dude falls out the window
and dies he takes off and that's like so
that's like the first half of the movie
then
we kind of hard cut to him
being in a carnival and he
is uh trying i guess he's trying to keep
stuff on the dl
and he's like um taking on the name uh
mr mentallo i think is his name he's
like you know
magic mind or whatever and because he
can see through everybody's [ __ ] like he
can see
into your pockets he can see and so he
can like figures out your name how much
money you've got so he has like a whole
act going
interestingly the guy that i don't know
if he runs the carnival but he's sort of
like the guy that's managing
uh ray milan's character is played by
don rickles which i think was maybe
for you youngsters he was like a really
famous comedian back in the day this
might be this is a straight role he's
not like funny in it
he does kind of make some funny quips uh
here and there but it's not it's it's a
largely um
serious role and it's largely like he's
kind of a villain a little bit
not so much a villain just kind of like
he just wants to make money right
uh so raymalan's character dr xavier
who's going under mr matalo there's kind
of a thing where he's
dressed up in this like ridiculous
looking uh you know
woo-woo kind of robe and he has this
thing around his eyes that has like a
big huge eyeball on it
and he can see through it obviously and
he can see through everybody and so he
has an
act and a lot of people just think he's
like it's a trick or he's faking
as you would but don rickles character
actually does believe
that he can do what he actually says he
can do
and so he has the idea like to make some
money is like we should
set up essentially like a free clinic
and all these people will come by and
you can tell people what's really wrong
with them because you can actually see
inside of their bodies
and then we'll like you know tell them
what's wrong they can go to a doctor and
then
you know we'll say it's free but they'll
give us donations anyway
and we'll like make bank
so that is actually what they end up
doing they don't really like each other
like uh you know ramble land and he's
getting more and more
crazy because as i said the the more the
drops
take effect on him you know whether it's
affecting his brain or whatever but he's
starting to see
more and more and in a lot of the film
you kind of see things from his point of
view i mean you have to think this movie
was like very very
uh cheap it's very low budget um it only
cost 300 000
to make i think and it only took three
weeks to shoot it that said
i think it's actually kind of cool the
way they show stuff from his perspective
it's basically just
when you see things from his perspective
everything is just kind of like
blurred and like rainbowy and prismy and
[ __ ] like that
so it's tr it's trying to show that
the longer the movie goes on he's just
starting to see things that are like
outside the
the kin of like maybe things in like
other dimensions and stuff like that
and it's kind of driving him crazy like
i said i don't think they spell that out
entirely but i'm pretty sure that that's
what the implication was
so they set up this clinic and um
he has these people come and it's just
kind of like this real uh
ramshackle operation and people come in
there and he's like yeah you know
you have you know lung cancer or
whatever and then he starts
you know getting all these donations so
they start making all this money
then it turns out that dr fairfax
because i think like a month has gone by
like they don't really
say until later on because like i said
it's a pretty hard cut like in the
middle where he's just suddenly
set up at a carnival now but dr fairfax
has spent she said i spent a month
tracking you down and i found you so i'm
not really sure if she wants him to
come back because like he's still in
trouble and [ __ ] like that but i think
maybe
the implication being like she's in love
with him and she wants to like help him
you know a fresh start or whatever so
when she turns up he decides he don't
want to do this uh
this thing with don rickles anymore and
uh
so then he's like i just i need more
money i need more money for my research
i'm almost out of serum it's
like i said it's really strange that
even though
it's clear that this serum is driving
him crazy he still wants to
make more of it and he still wants to go
farther but like i said i think the
implication being that one he's addicted
to the [ __ ]
or two it's like starting to affect his
brain i guess that's an andor so he gets
the idea
that he's like i know where i where we
can get money to continue my research
we're gonna go to vegas baby
and he's because he's gonna be able to
see through all the cards he can see
through everybody else's cards he can
see through all the dealers so it's like
you know he can even see into like the
slot machine so he knows like when it's
going to hit
and all this other kind of stuff which
i'm i wasn't entirely sure how that
worked but i guess okay whatever
so they go to vegas and uh you know he
starts when obviously he starts like
making all this money
and see this is where i think that it's
implied that he's kind of not really
thinking [ __ ] through anymore because
if you actually could see through [ __ ]
right and you decided
as you would uh to go to vegas and win a
bunch of money
you would think you'd want to keep kind
of you know low-key
about it because i don't know if you
guys know but when you go casinos if you
go to a casino and you start winning a
whole bunch
that they're gonna watch out and they're
gonna think you're cheating somehow
and you're not gonna get away with it
because they keep an eye on all that
crap
because you know people know how to
count cards and [ __ ] like that but he's
very
kind of like hey yeah [ __ ] yeah man i
can see you've got this and you've got
that and i was like yeah you're
gonna be it's like yeah the mafia is
gonna break your [ __ ] kneecaps
just shut up and take the money but he
ends up getting like twenty thousand
dollars or whatever but like i said you
know the the casino people are just kind
of like what the [ __ ] he up to he's
you know
cheating so they kick him out he's just
like [ __ ] this and throws all the money
everywhere
and then he just basically takes off you
know he gets away from dr fairfax
and he's just like [ __ ] lost it he
goes off in the car
and drives through the desert and
obviously he shouldn't really be driving
because all he can see is like this
ever shifting patterns of prismic light
and it should be noted too that there's
one great scene because like i said the
second half of the movie he's wearing
those really really dark sunglasses the
whole time so you don't know what the
[ __ ] going on behind there like with
his eyeballs and why not
so at some point he whips the or
somebody takes the
the sunglasses off and he has his eyes
are like the whites of them are all
black
but then like the middle part is gold
like shiny gold
and i will say this was 19 1963
this movie was made they didn't have you
know little
contact lenses like we have now they're
just made of like bendy plastic or
whatever
so if you see people wearing contact
lenses in movies prior to
i'm not really sure when the crossover
was prior to like 70s maybe
or maybe even the 80s then they were
made of thick glass
which you can tell these probably were
and they would kill your eyes you could
only wear them for like a minute or two
before your eyes would just start
watering everywhere so the fact that
rainbow land went the
distance and was like yeah i'll wear
these [ __ ] things because because
they look really good it looks like
really creepy
i mean for 1963 it's obviously they
would do it with cgi nowadays probably
or with just like little bendy contact
lenses but back then just big thick
[ __ ] contact lenses so there's these
black eyes with this gold in the middle
and everybody's like what the [ __ ] that
is like crazy looking so like i said he
takes off from the casino and he's
driving around
he can't really see anything because he
sees through everything which like i
said would be
[ __ ] horrifying you wouldn't be able
to drive you'd be able to do anything
and it's like he's gotten to a point too
where he's just like he looks up at the
ceiling because like i said he can't
sleep because he can see through his
eyelids
and he looks up through the ceiling and
he's if he's like in a building and he
can see
everybody like up through the up through
the [ __ ] building like all the way to
the top and i'm like that would be like
[ __ ] horrific
but that's what i meant about the idea
for this being like really really
horrible like if you thought it through
because i was like yeah you would not
want this [ __ ]
so he is like is taken off he's driving
all over the [ __ ] road because he
can't really see
and then he crashes and then he lives
but he gets out and he kind of stumbles
into
this uh tent revival and at
which point like you see his face and
now his eyes are just completely black
and he gives this speech and it's so
funny because i didn't realize
that this speech that he gives like this
monologue where he's telling
the preacher like what he's like he's
like i want to tell you what i can see
and he's basically implying that he can
see another dimension where he can see
like the center of the universe
and uh if you guys know the the there
was a cover
of black sabbath's super knot that was
done
i don't remember what year it was in the
80s or 90s done by
um a thousand homo djs which was a
ministry
sideband and they in a couple of the
mixes of that song
they pretty they put pretty much this
whole monologue
in there like i want to tell you what i
can see it's like i see great darknesses
and all this other stuff
so it's like as soon as i heard that in
the movie i just like lost my [ __ ]
because i was like oh my god super
naught
it was just really really funny really
really funny moment because i knew it
was a sample from a movie but i didn't
realize it was from this movie
so fun fact if you look that song up all
the stuff in the middle about you know
in the center of the universe the eye
you know what i mean
that's all from this movie so that's
what he's telling at the end
now he's trying to tell them all of this
but then of course the preacher is just
kind of like no you just see sin and the
devil
and uh you know what they say in the
bible if thine eye offends
they pluck it out and so he's like yeah
that sounds like a good idea
and then he puts his eyes like that he
goes he puts his hands like that and he
goes out of frame
and then he comes back up and there's a
still shot and like i said there's a
still shot and it's very very brief
where they're trying to imply that he
tore his own eyeballs out but obviously
in 1963 you couldn't really show that
uh and with the budget that this movie
was shot on they couldn't really show
that either
so it's basically just a still photo of
raymond with like the eyes
cut out of the photo and then there's
like red light behind it you know it
doesn't
look all that great by today's standards
obviously but it was 1963
that you know they did the best they
could with uh the budget that they had
and they and you know to their credit to
roger corman's credit he didn't linger
on it um he just kind of showed it for a
second like implying that he
tore his eyes out and that's pretty much
the end of the movie
now roger corman i think
wrote the screenplay for this although i
think the the screenplay is credited to
ray russell and somebody else who's ray
russell was like actually quite a
well-known uh
you know short story like a horror
writer at the time and he wrote some
sci-fi as well i think he wrote
sardonicus if i'm not mistaken although
i could be wrong about that if somebody
wants to correct me in the comments i'm
sure someone will
but um the funny thing about this when i
first read about this movie
in stephen king's dance macabre he
he made the observation and keep in mind
that when stephen king wrote this
you couldn't and this is like so funny
like younger people are gonna like freak
out
but you couldn't just go back and watch
a movie um so he was just going by his
memory of it
and he said that he's like oh the the
rumor was when this movie came out
that there was actually another scene
after the end scene like after he had
torn his eyes out and that there was
another couple seconds in the movie that
they had cut out because it was too
horrifying
and he's like that last couple seconds
was ray milan saying i can still see
even though his eyes were gone which
would have been a rad
[ __ ] ending so somebody asked roger
corman about that and he's like is that
true like did they take that out and
he's like
no it's not true he's like but now i'm
cut well he i'm paraphrasing but he said
now i'm kind of pissed because like
stephen king said that in the book and
he's like that was a better ending than
mine
so it's like so he would have done it if
he'd thought of it but i guess he didn't
but that actually would have been really
cool now i read not too long ago or
maybe it was a few years ago i thought
that tim burton was gonna do a remake of
this
which actually i think this would be a
decent movie to remake even though the
one from 1963 is really good and like
surprisingly effective for being as old
as it is
i think this would be kind of cool with
like a modern uh
sort of flair to it because like i said
it almost has
it almost has a little bit of a cosmic
horror kind of thing because just
not so much overtly but it's just kind
of like in the implications of it
that if you could actually see
everything and you could see like all
the visible sp
visible spectrum you can see all the
invisible spectrum and then you would
start seeing
through everything and like i said you
could even see in other dimensions and
stuff
there's definitely a love lovecraftian
uh kind of aspect to that and i think
that would make a
a really good film with like maybe like
a larger budget um
and a more modern sensibility and uh i
think that would actually be really good
so
so in that case even though i really
really liked this movie i wouldn't be
averse to seeing a modern remake of it
because i think it's a great
idea and uh you know it's just a it
would be a horrifying uh movie
if done correctly i meant to mention too
that like when i was talking about uh
super knot that bauhaus on their uh 1981
album mask
also had they have a song called the man
with the x-ray eyes which
is kind of they're kind of talking about
this movie i guess like their lyrics are
kind of abstract
abstract but um they they kind of could
be
talking about this movie sure you know
why not but yeah if you're into 60s
horror if you like roger corman
movies you know if you like that era of
sci-fi then this is one that i would
definitely recommend this is definitely
one of the better
roger corman movies that i've seen for
sure and um definitely one of the better
like 60s sci-fi films just because the
idea of it is so horrifying
it's got like some weird tonal [ __ ] in
there because like i said you know
the scene with them at the party with
the really awkward dancing and all the
naked people and stuff
you know it was like there was kind of
funny goofy stuff in there but
uh on the whole it's like pretty serious
and
it's kind of like a [ __ ] up idea and
it kind of went farther a little bit
ahead of its time
i feel like just you know concept wise
but yeah if you want to watch it i would
recommend it um like i said
particularly if you like that era of
sci-fi um it's on 2b at the moment for
free you might also be able to watch it
on youtube for free kind of uh forgotten
even in roger corman's circles i don't
really see that many people talking
about it
but i was really happy that i finally
got to see it because i just remembered
stephen king talking about it so long
ago
and i finally got around to watching it
and i'm glad i did because i really
dug it quite a bit so that'll do it for
this flickers of fear i will see
you guys on the next one bye